that lo of the YouTube community very
very cool
community and I'm not just saying X I'm
here and the cold Davos Switzerland
we're here at the World Economic Forum
I'm a young global leader my name is I'm
sorry I'm a member the end Global
Leaders we will not want to suggest that
I am a leader here at the web my name is
John Hope Bryant and I'm the founder of
Operation Hope which America's first
nonprofit social investment bank I'm
also vice chairman of the President's
Council on financial literacy in the
United States by the President on this
past Tuesday which speak Lee speaks to
the question what's the one thing that
the companies that governments that
organizations that individuals like you
can do to make the world a better place
I believe that one person can change the
world and when you think about people
who change the world with all due
respect to all the great people who are
here many of those people had no titles
Jesus Christ was a carpenter mother
Teresa was a nurse Nelson Mandela from
27 years was a prisoner Martin Luther
King jr. was a southern preacher my
friend Andrew Young my mentor civil
rights leader and a reverend but one
person change the world so what's the
one thing that we should do when it's
the one thing we could do I think we
need to move from civil rights to civil
rights I think that we need to empower
people he's not to give them a handout
but a hand up to not focus as a lot of
hepatic philanthropy is on and a lot of
government services are focused on
giving a man a fish but teaching how to
fish
I remember Martin Luther King jr. told
Andrew Young a story that really wasn't
made public back then it wasn't
politically correct he was on the
Jericho Road in Israel and the media
kept saying Martin you remind me of the
good the Good Samaritan lived on the
Jericho Road dr. King said to Andrew
Young said Andy we need good Samaritans
I respect that Samaritans I I want a
good Samaritan to be in my community but
I don't want to be a good Samaritan the
Jericho Road is dangerous
I don't want to pick up my people
sitting like a victim sitting on the
edge of the Jericho Road anymore
we to fix the Jericho Road we need to
pay the Jericho Road
lady put street lights up along the
Jericho Road we need to build Community
Development and homeownership and small
business and entrepreneurship among the
Jericho Road we need to create
entrepreneurs and educated people along
the Jericho Road Andie we need to fix
the Jericho Road and when he was killed
doctor who was killed in 68 April 2 CA
he was focused on the for people's
campaign and that was about poor whites
is more poor whites in America than for
anybody else poor blacks Latinos for
Asian for Indians for african-americans
well I think I was moving all up the
economic ladder because he eat and he
said this it satiate you cannot
legislate goodness you cannot pass a lot
for someone to respect you the only way
to social justice in a capitalist
country is economic parity ownership
there's nothing more appropriate than
this Davos conversation then looking at
the least of these God's children
looking at the fact that we integrated
the lunch counter in 68-63 1960 in the
US but never we never integrated the
dollar or the Euro or the zem dollar
whatever it is the currency you're
dealing with the systems was Frank and
so I think that's the thing that we can
do is to teach people about civil rights
teach them about financial literacy
teaching them a lot of free enterprise
and capitalism and ownership if you're
living in a little shanty town in South
Africa
you live in Alexandria in South Africa
you don't have running water you don't
have you don't have lights you don't
even have solid walls but on every
street corner is the black woman doing
here
that's an entrepreneur on every corner
and in every block there is a little
kiosk selling cell phone of cell phones
and cell phone minutes by little carts
that have cell phone in time those are
those are entrepreneurs we are natural
entrepreneurs
poor people are natural entrepreneurs
people don't realize that Sam Walton
Walmart was a
uneducated poor white male from the
south who we allow the poor people
wanted good products at a good price
and voila now you have the largest
retailer in the world and more people
have made most the fortunes in the world
we got to stop making fortunes in the
back before people and start making
fortune developers out of poor people
and I think that's something that all of
us can do teach financial literacy teach
dignity go on your community and
understand you cannot be a leader
illiterate to serve all around this
world we got to continue the work that
dr. King began and launch a global
silver rights movement if we do that you
don't have to worry about more aid for
South Africa because you're getting
people to hand up our effort at the
African continent or Latin America or
the poor places in Asia playing
porpoises in Latin America the six
billion people has planted three half of
which living on a dollar a day you know
that's not sustainable it's not dignity
is not what we deserve what people want
is an opportunity to succeed or fail on
their own merry and if you want to feel
good about yourself help somebody help
themselves and if we do that we create a
generation of entrepreneurs in Africa
they'll become taxpayers so become job
producers in Africa will not be the Dark
Continent it'll be a place of
opportunity and prosperity because it is
an amazing beautiful place that will
take its place as one of the leaders in
the 21st century and you can help make
that reality everybody will make a
difference you be there one person five